hi my name is Tamra chambers I'm Cody
Melcher and this is Tamra Jessa and Cody
just saw also too as well we just saw a
ghost in the shelf we did yeah everyone
agrees that's too much excitement for
this movie uh yeah what's LED Sugar's
low so let's start this off by saying we
did not see the anime beforehand yes I
looked up what it's about
basically I watched yugioh growing up I
assume same thing it's Amalur actually
the sea yeah I've seen Blade Runner so
I've also seen this movie if you watch
Blade Runner well also on a ton of
vicodin ah you have seeing this film
have you ever been cornered at a party
and some weird person you've never
spoken to before has explained the plot
of Blade Runner to you and has also had
way too much like beer yes then you've
seen this motivator I hated her design
but as we were saying we don't know if
she looks like that in the anime mainly
her nakedness
yeah well all the time her being naked
for a chunk of the time kind of I guess
could make sense if the idea was that
like when she goes invisible
she needs to be naked but they also
managed to shoot other reasons for her
to be naked like one point she take off
her wetsuit and it was like did we
really need to watch her take off her
wetsuit for that split moment every time
she got slightly hurt like the first
time she got hurt her arm had just
fiddling gashed a bit and I know it hurt
like further into her like neuro network
programming yeah yeah that's way more
technical than I was gonna be so
programmation and I feel like a little
bit of light armor would have maybe help
with that why does she have to be naked
the whole time you can implant x-ray
eyes into a person I feel like you can
figure out a way to allow her to go
invisible without there being nude in a
gun situation where she is also going
back to the ice
where they're putting that and I love
that design so that was super cool
basset hound seemed cool with him so
yeah or is it a beagle that's young
no I think maybe a mix because it would
definitely a basset hound
I don't actually know the difference
between beagle and Bassett house and it
was a lot that I'm finding this more
interesting in that whole movie yeah it
was definitely bad combo but he had the
coloration of beagle so maybe perhaps it
was a Corky
wearing a basset hound costume a ghost
in the show we're gonna do our best
during the review to say ghost in the
shell' as many times they do during a
movie which is every other sentence uh
impossibly I already failed it wins the
award for most mentions of the title of
the film and also quickest cause like
reverse team they refer to her as a
ghost in a shell and I was like wow
we're just gonna hit it right on the
nose yeah here we go oh my the action is
awful
it's so boring like a ghost in a shell I
want to talk first about like grabbing
our attention which lead actors did not
do you talked about this how you blame
more the writing and the direction which
I agree everybody in the movie was bland
we monotonous like everybody spoke at
the exact same town even when people
were upset they were still talking in
that very like FBI agent tone I think I
just blame it more on Scarlett Johansson
then I showed it because it's just in
place so look into her vocal register
Scarlett Johansson was always on her low
vocal register and it was just bothering
me so much because it wasn't interesting
at all there's moments at the end when
you really are supposed to be feeling
for this character and the struggles
that she's going through and you just do
not care at all there's people behind us
laughing they were having fun I don't
know but they were not they're having
fun outside of the movie if it tells you
how boring and monotonous this movie is
a man got up and walked out during the
ending of the movie like Scarlett
Johansson is doing a voiceover the movie
is wrapped up is very clear that this
movie is going to be over and a man
good up in the middle of a theater and
walked out he's like I'm not wasting any
more time on this movie I have done I
don't care the cat walking through the
frame has been more interesting than
that movie was to see you buddy really
great work actually no you can do better
this story felt like I had seen as a
hundred million times but I'm like have
I or is it just boring I think both well
you can get true and it's what I meant
by like it's an action movie with us
with philosophy trying to put into it
because it's like it's a it's a boring
lazy philosophy movie all we are is dust
in the wind like a ghost in a shell the
city was bothering me so much I couldn't
get past it so giant like hologram but
why were they there right I won and it
made no sense in the world the design of
the city felt like someone at LucasArts
needed to turn in a project and he fell
asleep watching Blade Runner and woke up
the next morning he was like oh god I
just threw something together I loved
loved the design of the Geisha spiders
there should be a Geisha spider spin off
it's just gauge the spider like stop
remaking spider-man and let's just get
geisha spider Willem Dafoe can be in it
yeah I see it it's going to be great
geisha spider voiced by Tobey Maguire
well now you versus I thought we wanted
you to be interesting not just as
monotonous as this movie was all right
Andrew Garfield I know loves geishas
spiders yes it was creepy in a way that
I wanted this movie to have creepiness
in a way that I imagine the anime
Jimmy's right right there was some the
real design elements that we're really
engaging and interesting even though you
know as a greater whole it was it felt
kind of rehash there were some small
elements to it that you could definitely
tell we're probably from the anime like
that they were directly transposing them
like Watchmen style yeah onto the thing
her whole team was great I would watch I
would watch that like I've watched the
rogue one of of goes to the shill where
it's not her and it's just all the
people that work at the department don't
really get any more of them until like
an hour and a half in when the movie
almost becomes interesting again and
then they're like nope you thought wrong
there was also and a brief moment you're
like oh hell yeah this anime Avengers is
assembly and it's going to be very cool
and it's very excited about it they're
like no no you don't actually get to see
anything about them I keep coming back
to saying that like she's not
interesting in this but she's not sorry
ScarJo
I'm sorry ScarJo sorry we're so cool
right cool great she persisted to
pretend she really is a ghost in this
gesture there's no way that this anime
that is so beloved is about this
character that is not cool and
interesting at all so she goes and she
sees her mother and her mother doesn't
recognize her because she's been made
into a white white woman um which was an
interesting choice Wow
yes yeah why it's one thing to make the
lead actress white and it's like an
adaptation from an anime I understand
that there might be production reasons
for marketing or something you know that
was the argument behind the Chinese wall
was Matt Damon was the director wanted
to have a star because he didn't think
American audiences would go to it if it
was somebody they didn't know from China
it's another thing to in the movie she
is a Japanese teenager turned into a
white robot and I mean I could feel like
there's a lot of culturally that could
be read into the most exciting part of
the movie for me was when I went to the
bathroom Midway and somebody had left
the door to the Logan theater open I'm
not kidding that was hands-down the most
exciting part of the movie for a big
another thing that I did like I want to
talk about those things as much as
possible
I liked the like bad guy lackeys that
they had they all kind of similar they
all had weird mechanicals but like
rotted out peace oh the Yakuza
it was a Yakuza club I don't know if
you'd necessarily like all of it you
Lackey for Yakuza look and in the Venn
diagram of Yakuza and Lackey there's
some overlap but it's not all the same
sorry please explain to me what you can
is oh the Yakuza is a Japanese like the
Japanese mafia age' it's a Japanese
mafia group yes I know that thanks to
rush hour okay I am NOT safe I'm also I
just I also just know that okay this is
the list of things Cody just happened to
know reason when I was big list there
are lots of elements in the design that
are great yeah but the overall design
felt uninspired I think would be the
best way of putting it I was just so
glad that you were there because what I
wouldn't have finished the movie would
walk out it would have closed walked out
yeah as we were separating - I wouldn't
I don't think I will just make this
video I think I probably would have
emailed channel awesome it'd have been
like I'm so sorry I can't I can't
and yet I cannot do it I was so
disappointed in this oh there was a cat
it's safe to the movie I want to hear
what people think who have not only seen
the anime but just who just like deeply
loved the anime I really love to hear
what you think if you like it I'm just
gonna be like I just got to see the
anime
I mean honestly my takeaway was I just
want to go watch the anime because like
because it seemed I will give the movie
credit that it because of the individual
elements it seemed interesting enough
that I am convinced that the anime is
probably far more interesting and so it
actually does make me want to go watch
the anime but it seems like a very
expensive project to just drive people
to the end of it I like your blue hair
blue hair it's okay next week we
get to watch Smurfs